british airways virgin atlantic in the
skies above london
fierce competitors on the u.s market for
37 years taking off simultaneously today
from london's heathrow airport both
flying to new york's jfk
both deploying airbus a350 1000s
the airbus a350 1000 of virgin atlantic
was uh taking off there from uh runway
27l british airways flight taking off
from runway 27
r for the occasion british airways
carrying the flight number
ba001 the former concorde flagship
flight
number and
joining us now is the virgin atlantic
ceo shave right hello tj thanks for
joining us uh quite the day for you
big day yeah 600 days of the border
being shut down for uk nationals going
uh to the us so a dramatic day but it's
really lovely to see the
you know the families reuniting with
loved ones uh grand grandparents who
have not seen their groud children
people going on honeymoon relatedly so a
fantastic day for aviation of course for
virgin atlantic and our people
okay now tell me what happened a little
bit earlier on you took off
on parallel runways with british airways
that must have taken some organizing
it took a lot of organizing and 37 years
in the making so at 8 50 today two
a350-1000 the most efficient planes in
our fleet both respective fleets took
off from london heathrow into jfk and
the competition will not be who gets
there the quickest but rather who get
there on time uh with the most efficient
use of fuel so fantastic day highly
coordinated synchronized
takeoff
yeah looking at uh the noses both going
up simultaneously that was so
impressive
and as you say very symbolic indeed how
quickly do you think you're going to be
able to return to pre-pandemic levels
it's such an important route for both
airlines isn't it they won across the
channel across the atlantic
yeah at virgin transit we say that we
wouldn't be virgin without the atlantic
60 of our capacity is to the us and by
april of 2022 we expect to have as many
sectors as as many seats across the
atlantic now take up will be
i think unpredictable for a bit but
we're already seeing very strong demand
for christmas
for easter and the summer and of course
this week is absolutely full
to the reams about 100 capacity and 100
take up of the seats now business travel
will follow and we don't know exactly
how the impact of technology will be on
the business traveler but we're already
seeing signs of the small to
medium-sized enterprises moving
to travel and of course the large
corporations will follow people do
business with people
and zoom and teams and slack is a very
good use of technology but it is not a
substitute for a face-to-face meeting
shay what checks or rules are in place
for once you get onto the aeroplane i'm
guessing masks still and the like
yeah of course and i think uh aviation
has proven that travel is safe and the
advancements of course of the vaccine
and the medicines but on board the
cleanliness of the planes the need to
wear masks our crews have been tested
throughout the pandemic before they get
on board and of course with all the
procedures of pre-departure testing and
upon arrival testing i think travel is
safe and should give people comfort that
they can use
the planes to connect with the loved
ones into business to reunite with their
colleagues and partners to get things
done and get this very important
uh travel corridor back to its uh normal
and best place
okay i wonder if i could just explore
with you in a little bit more detail
obviously it's cop 26 at the moment
we're all trying to cut our carbon
emissions um
and yet we see two um a350s taking off
simultaneously to take people to the
united states what can passengers do to
try to be more environmentally aware
yeah so of course cough 26 is a major
event and aviation needs to do its part
we've all committed to becoming net zero
by 2050 but that's a long way away so
we're doing things right now the things
that airlines should do is have the
youngest fleet in the sky
next generation planes the one like the
ones that took off here today from
heathrow 68 of our fleet is next
generation
and in terms of the travelers um you
know they should be conscious you know
the day trip to brussels the day trip to
new york maybe not the best use of time
but combining leisure and business into
a longer trip is the thing to do being
smart about who you travel with and of
course the airlines and everybody around
us governments financiers the oil majors
need to play a part that action towards
net zero doesn't wait another 10 years
but actually happens every single day
from now on
it's a great day for you and for british
airways
today but how concerned are you perhaps
niggling in the back of your mind that
the kovid rates are increasing here you
know they are very high in the united
states hundreds of thousands of people
have died there more than about
and forty thousand have died here in the
united kingdom that potentially were not
out of the woods yet
absolutely look uh
there is no doubt that the covet
pandemic has had a devastating effect on
the lives and livelihoods of so many at
virgil atlantic in an airline in general
we know this better than anyone but i
think the difference is that the
vaccination rates being so high and the
efficacy is so good and the fact that
there are new procedures coming online
gives me confidence that we are moving
forward rather than backwards and yes
the pandemic has thrown curveballs at
all of us and we've learned to adapt but
i think it is
a testament of the scientists the
governments the nhs that we are in this
position right now to serve customers
families businesses and reuniting travel
is safe
so we encourage people to absolutely
adhere to the rules put a mask on do the
test take a vaccine and then travel
should be able to connect you with your
loved ones
why didn't you fly to jfk today we
believe the chief exec of british
airways was on board his flight
yes and you know uh
someone has to do uh things differently
we're here there's plenty of stuff to
cover here in the united kingdom and of
course it's business as usual so this is
a very big day of celebration
but
my job continues and i'm sure sean is
having a great time on his flight to the
united states
i'm sure when are you next going
[Music]
i don't know yet but probably in the new
year
okay fun just before i let you go
looking at these two flights taking off
and how did that work did you have to
close the runway where the planes
normally land so that you could get them
both to take off at the same time i
don't really understand
yeah indeed here i think you're
absolutely right so this is uh it's
unprecedented in terms of british
airways and virgin atlantic cooperating
this way but it just shows us that when
we are faced with great
you know great challenges and
difficulties we must unite and indeed
one was using the takeoff one was the
landing it was 850 synchronous uh
takeoff a really beautiful side to
memory uh you know to commemorate this
very
special day of celebration of opening
the uh borders after 600 days
okay shea vice and ceo of virgin
atlantic great to talk to you
congratulations it all went very
smoothly good to talk to you thank you